[Music]
now arthritis is a simple mineral
deficiency disease we learn how to
prevent and cure arthritis 300 years ago
we learned how to prevent a cure but I
have bone to bone arthritis doctor
wallet I don't care if it's bone to bone
arthritis I don't care if you've had
that for 20 years and you're in such
pain now no medication works to help the
pain doctors have talked you into double
knee replacement and you're scheduled
tomorrow you call them say I'm going to
delay it until after January because I'm
gonna try this doc Wallach mighty 90s
stuff give it 90 days and see what
happens even if you have bone to bone
North's right even if they have
surgically removed your meniscus we can
rebuild it praise God we do it for
athletes all the time we do it for
people in the military all the time we
do it to regular people like you and me
thousands of times a month thousands of
times a month next there's going to be
an epidemic of arthritis in America here
why is that because there's 80 million
baby boomers come along and they have 72
joints 10 toes 2 ankles who needs two
hips 33 vertebrae to shoulders 2 elbows
to wrists and ten fingers and every
artha peak surgeon is running up and
down the aisles at churches saying
Alleluia thank you lord there's 80
million babies coming baby boomers come
along they have 72 joints it I'm gonna
replace of all but all you have to do is
take the mighty 90 and stay away from
the bad stuff you'll never get arthritis
I'm 71 years old okay if this is a
harder surface I could stand here on one
foot because I got a lot of padding up
here I can stay on one foot for three
hours and give the lecture as you'll see
in a minute you'll see why okay next
Bell's palsy he still baffles doctors
for 200 years they've been doing
research trying to figure it out we've
known for 300 years what causes just a
manifestation of osteoporosis of your
skull bones squeezing the seventh
cranial nerve you treat it nutritionally
as osteoporosis as it goes away
just head simple next it's C
okay who told you to give up sunlight
who told you not to take vitamins and
minerals you get everything from your
food C vitamin d3 deficiency which every
doctor is now is taking blood tests to
see what your vitamin d3 level is that's
another physician cause disease nobody
in a third-world country has vitamin d3
deficiency it's an American disease
caused by dermatologists okay next even
non cola drinks like 7up and stuff like
that Dr Pepper those kind of things
Pepsi Cola Coca Cola that you don't want
to be drinking carbonated drinks during
meals because they will actually
neutralize your stomach acid so you
cannot absorb minerals or digest
proteins or b12 next that's medical you
see the medical industry their answer to
arthritis is pain relief and surgically
change in your knees out and your hips
and your elbows and shoulders and
fingers right why not regrow your own
does God have arthritis no did Jesus say
here's a carpenter did he have arthritis
no and you and I are built in the image
of God because the Bible tells us so
right so if God didn't have arthritis
and cancer and heart disease and
diabetes and hemorrhoids why should we
okay hallelujah okay next okay that by
ox had painkiller headed it was the best
painkiller ever invented but it had a
little side effect it killed 85,000
people okay next
Fosamax and boniva shame on you Sally
Field actually causes fractures next
okay let's see here look at that no knee
surgery for arthritis is useless
worthless
that's from Harvard Medical School
published in the New England Journal of
Medicine next well this guy was the
president of of McDonald's Corporation
and had for seven years ago had double
arthroscopic surgeries every year so he
could play golf and a seventh year he
actually had a double knee replacement
because he got
weary of those procedures he was in such
pain he had to take oxycontin couldn't
do his job properly and they fired him
the board fired him from a hundred
million dollar a year job because he had
double knee replacement and of course
every time he kind of tries to call the
orthopedic surgeon who did that to him
the surgeon looks as his oh that's a
Ralph we're not going to answer his
phone okay next
okay back surgery is unnecessary we can
support and promote healthy maintenance
and repair which means we can regrow
your discs why would you have surgery
when you can regrow your own discs with
a little bit of supplements well my
doctor said you mean the one who lives
b56
next men and women get osteoporosis not
a postmenopausal woman's disease next
this is just 2010 okay men and women
both getting osteoporosis next you know
how Cleopatra got her calcium there's
kind of a peasant's thing to get it from
limestone an oyster cell shows she put
pearls in vinegar and drank that vinegar
pearl mix every day $5,000 a day for
calcium supplements we get ours is a lot
cheaper
okay next those top two are the ones the
middle to the middle to the healthy
starter pack and a liquid classic we'll
talk about that next we want to think of
the mighty 90 and then every time you
have a disease you want to take
something special for that disease
that's why we have the flower concept
next next next next next next next okay
that's me that's my bone density test
you can see me up there at five point
five I'm up there with 18 year-old male
athletes and I'm 71 years old and that's
because I've been doing the mighty 90
since I was 9 and during the mighty 90
since for 62 years thank you
thank you my blood pressure is 121 over
71 I've never been on a prescription
medication my resting pulse is 43 my
resting pulse is 43 huh now if I were to
go to a cardiologist he'd want to give
me a pacemaker he might put me on
medication he want to give me a heart
transplant but I bet I can outlast him
in a fight okay I just have to dodge him
for 56 years for you next
[Applause]